ก็
สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาร์ตี้
สวัสดีครับผมอ่ากลับมาเจอกับครัวตี้กับ
ครูพี่เอ๋ในช่องท่องเที่ยวสเปอร์ไทยนะ
ครับเดี๋ยวเค
ค่าอ๋อก่อนที่เราจะเรียนเราต้องรู้จักวัน
หน้ารู้จักวันครับวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้
วันนี้วันนี้วันพุธวันพุธวุฒิศักดิ์ครับ
วันนี้วันพุธหน้าวันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ 5
วันพุธวันที่
ที่
29 ครับน้า
ก้าวช้าๆวันนี้วันที่ 29
เดือนอะไรคะครูอาทิตย์เดือนนี้เดือน
ธันวาคม
เมื่อ
เดือนธันวาคม
ให้คอตต้าเท่าไหร่มีคศ
2010  20  11 ครับ
21 นะคะภายครับปีพตเท่าไหร่ปีพตต
2564 ครับ 5
2564 ชายครับครู Arty วันนี้วันพุธใช่
ครับพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรพรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสครับ
พรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสจะได้วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
อ่าวันพฤหัสวันที่
30 ครับนี่
วันนี้วันพุธพรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่ 30
ได้ขนาดนี้มะรืนนี้วันนี้
เตือนพรุ่งนี้
มะรืนนี้น้ามะรืนนี้วันที่ 3  31 ครับอ่า
วันที่ 31 ทรายครับ
เย้เย้วันที่ 31 เป็นวันอะไรครับวัน
วันสิ้นปี High เป็นวันสิ้นปีเลยครับ
2021 ไปลายทรายครับ 202
[เพลง]
12021 ไปแล้วนะอ่าวันนี้แล้วก็พรุ่งนี้
มะรืนนี้อีก 2 วันตายครับอีกสอบวายอีกวัน
นึงก็ปีมาเป็นวันที่ 1 นะครับอ่าวันที่ 1
ปีปี
2022 มีปี
2002 นะงกลัวตี้บัง 200  r22 อ่ะเป็นวัน
ปีใหม่เย้หน้าใช่ครับ
พี่ไก่อันนี้เป็นปีนี้ปีนี้ 202  1 ปี 4
ปีปีนี้เป็นปีหน้ากินอ้าอ้าปีหน้า
ปีหน้า 2022 ค่ะได้ครับปีหน้า 2022  OK
ครับงั้นคลิปนี้ก็เป็นคลิปสุดท้ายๆของ
421 ชายใจครับมาหน้าโอเค
คลิปสุดท้ายเวลา
ใกล้ๆปีใหม่ไส้ไหมมหาชัยครับ
ก็จะโอเคอาจจะมี tissue  Tape ได้บ้าน
ทำความสะอาดใช่ไหมอ่ะเนื้อหาบางทีดูบ้าน
ไม่โอเคก็อาจจะ
หา
ซ่อมบ้านใช่ไหมครับคอมอ่าน
คำบ้านซ่อมบ้าน
คลิปนี้กูอะตี้มีอะไร
อ้ากลับบ้านไหมคะอ้ามีมีเครื่องมือ
เครื่องมือซ่อมบ้านครับ 5 จอมมารใช่ครับ
หน้า
ให้ครับ R แต่ตอนนี้ครับตอนนี้ก่อนที่เรา
จะไปซ่อมบ้านตอนนี้เวลา
เวลา
4 โมง
45 นาทีครับหา 16:40 นตอนเย็นตอนเย็นใช่
ครับตอนเย็น
แต่ 16:00 น 15 นาทีๆครับหน้า
หน่อย
คู๋จะมืดมืด
ดำเลยใช่ไหมครับมืดกลางคืนโอเคค่ะเดี๋ยว
วันนี้ควรตีนแนะนำเครื่องมือเครื่องมือ
ช่างนับๆกู Arty มีมีภาพครึ่งมือช่างอีมี
ภาพเครื่องมือช่างทัพหน้าเครื่องมืออัน
ที่หนึ่งห่า
อะไรคะมือที่ 1 เรียกเรียกเลื่อยครับ
เหนื่อยอ่ะอ้าเรื่อยๆครับเรื่อยๆก็มีมี
ที่จับนะจะให้มีที่ตับอยู่ตรงนี้ใช้มือ
จับ
อ้ามือจับตรงนี้ครู Arty คะเรื่อยใช้กับ
จะไปหาอ้าเรื่อยเรื่อยๆใช้กับไม้ครับไม้
ไม้ 5 เพราะ
ครอบครัวตีก็เป็นไม้อ่านี่ที่กูอ่ะอยู่
เป็นไม้ใช้เรื่อยอ่ะอ่าใช่ครับมีข่าวกับ
ไม้ 5 ใช้กับไม้นี่ครับอะไรเป็นไม้หายนี่
มายนี่ใช้เลื่อยเลื่อยใช้ทำอะไรคะอ๋อ
เลื่อยคนไทยเรียกใช้เลื่อยไม้เลื่อยใช่
ครับหน้านี้ครับเอ้ยไม่ใช่ไม้ใช่ครับ
เลื่อยไม้นี่ขึ้นลงขึ้นลงเรื่อยเรื่อยๆๆ
ใช้มือจับตรงนี้จับจับแล้วก็เรื่อยหน้า
อะไรครับเรื่องเรื่อย
หือ Arty กูอัดอ่ะเอา
อยู่ใกล้มาเลื่อยไม้อ่าซ้ายครับนี่เอา
เลื่อยมาเลื่อยไม้อ่า
เห้ยโอเคเนาะอ่า
อุปกรณ์ซ่อมบ้านอันที่ 1 ก็คือ
เรื่อยไปครับใช้กับไม้ไม้ถูกต้องครับใช้
ทำอะไรนะอาจใช้เลื่อยเลื่อยหมายใช้อะไรมา
ใช้เรื่อยเรื่อยๆหมายฮ่าๆภาษาไทย
เรียกเหมือนกันนะเรื่อยเรื่อยๆไม้โอเค
ต่อไปมีอ้าอุปกรณ์ชิ้นทิศต่อ 2 ใช่ไหม
ครับหน้าอะไร Man
R5 ครูเอ๋รู้จักไม่รู้จักเฟอร์ตี้รู้นัก
เรียนก็รู้จักน่าอายเดี๋ยวครัวที่จะบอกคน
ไทยเรียกคนไทยเรียกว่าอะไรคะหาคนเขาเรียก
ค้อนขอร้อนใช้ครับฮ่าๆๆขอถอน
ค้อนมีที่จับไหมคะถ้ามีที่จับนี่ตรงนี้
เป็นที่จับทั้งหมดเลยเวลาจับเราใช้มือมือ
จับตรงนี้จับมือจับมือใหญ่มากตัวที่วาด
มือใหญ่มาก
โอเคนี่ใช้มือจับอะน่าได้ครับใช้มือจับ
จับค้อนอาศับปาร์ตี้ขอนใช้กับอะไรคะหน้า
คอนเราใช้กับตะปู
นี้นี่นี่ใช้กับสระปูหน่อยครับเออมีขอน
ขอน
อ่า
โทรนับรับใช้ทำอะไรน่าใช้ต่อครับคนไทย
เรียกต่อในครับอ่าป๊อกป๊อกป๊อกป๊อกป๊อกนะ
ตอบกูจะได้ขับ
ใช้ค้อนตอกตะปู
มี
เลื่อยนะครับใช้เลื่อยไม้อาบหน้าค้อนใช้
กับตะปู
ตะปูตอกตะปูไปครับโอเคมีอะไรอีกค่ะต่อไป
มีครับมี
นี้นี่
เรียกว่าอะไรอาทิตย์เรียกไขควงอ๋อไอ้ขั้ว
งอ่ะไขควงได้ครับช่วงนี้ใช้มือจับเหมือน
เดิมมือจับเป็ดอะเออใช่ครับมือจับหน้าใคร
ควงเวลาใช้งานเราก็
หมุนไหมคะใช่ครับหมุนหมุนหน้า
5 หมุนหมุน
[เพลง]
คุณครู Arty คะแล้วไขควงใช้กับอะไรคะค่ะ
ไขควงใช้กับสกรูครับนี่สกรูใช่ครับไขควง
คนไทยก็พูดสกรุใช่มั้ยใช่ครับสกรูไม่ได้
พูดเนาะอ่าไม่ใช่น้อยๆเดี๋ยวกวนตีนมี
พิรุจเดี๋ยวกลัวที่จะรูปนอนให้ดูแต่อัน
นี้อันนี้เป็นสกรูสกรู
เค้กคู๋ไม่เข้าใจ
อันนี้เป็นครูมาเวลาใช้งานใช้ไขควงใช้ไข่
ควงมีเสียบไว้ตรงนี้ถ้าเหยียบไขควงเข้าไป
อ่าใครพวงก็จะมีด้ามใช่ไหมค่ะแล้วเราก็
หมุนแล้วก็ให้จ่ายหมุนไปหมุนเอา
สกรูกล้าเข้าหรือออกก็ได้ได้ครับโทร
หา
หาไขควงสักครู่นะครับ
ต่อไปมีอะไรอีกคะไม่มีคีมนะครับอ่าเป็น
คีมมีครับทีมเป็นขี้อัดคีมตัดตัดอะไรคะ
ให้ครับครีมตัดที่มันนี้ใช้ตัดตัดสายไฟ
สายไฟนี่ครับเป็นสายแบบนี้ครับสายไฟหาสาย
ไฟป๊านะครับสาย
สายโทรศัพท์
ครีมก็ใช้กับสายไฟฟ้าใช่ครับ 5 ครีมใช้
กับสายไฟฟ้าครับใช้ทำอะไรนะคะอ่าใช้ตัด
ตัดสายไฟฟ้าใช้ครับ
ราคาอยู่อ่ะ
ที่ที่จับยาวๆฮ่าที่กราบตรงนี้ใช่ครับจับ
สองด้านเราใช้มือจากนะมือคืนจับหมูตรงนี้
ใช่ครับมาแล้วก็มีอ่านิ้วโป้งอีกข้างนึง
อีกข้างหนึ่งแล้วก็
คอร์ด e  y ในเหมือนคนแก้นิ้วโป้งจะอยู่
ด้านโน้นโอเคอ่าอันนี้เป็นมืออันนี้เป็น
นิ้วค่ะอ่านจับอ่าโอเค
แล้วก็ค่ะใต้แล้วก็ตัดสายไฟตรงนี้เออ
โอเคก็เป็นครีมนะคะใช้กับสายไฟ
สายไปต้องมีค่า
นี่ภาคอื่นอีกไหมค่ะต่อไปนะครับภาพต่อไป
เป็นภาพอะไรช้า
อ่านี่ครับเป็นภาพประแจ
แอๆครับนี่มีประแจประแจมีตรงนี้ครับตรง
นี้ใช้ใช้
นีบนีบกับน็อต
อันไหนคือ North อ้า not ปัจแจใช้กับใช้
กับน๊อตอ๋อ
มีครับน๊อตอ้าวโอเคมีน๊อต 2 แบบคนไทย
เรียกตัวนี้ตัวนี้น็อตเรียกว่าอะไรคะตอน
นี้เรียกน๊อตตัวผู้
on เรียกว่าน้ำตัวผู้ครับนายกรมกลมๆมีลง
สีถ้าตัวนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะเรียกน็อตตัว
เมียเรียกว่าน็อตตัวน๊อตตัวมีแขกงั้น
คุณแม่ก๊อตใช้กับน๊อตและใช้ทำอะไรกับน็อต
ค่าประแจใช้ขันขานขันน๊อตขันน๊อตตัวเมีย
เอาน๊อตตัวเมียมาใส่ตรงนี้ค่ะ 5 แล้วใช้
ประแจขันขันน็อตเข้าไป
ใจครับอ๊อดเข้าไปใช่ครับแล้วก็หมูขันน็อต
เข้าไป
ขันน๊อตตัวเมียได้
ขันน๊อตตัวผู้ได้อ้าใช่ครับขันได้ 2 ด้าน
not เลยอ่ะใช้ครับ
โอเค
ครูเอ๋ไม่เคยซ่อมบ้านไม่เคยใช้อะไรอ่ะพูด
อะไร
อาหาโอเคอ่ามีบีอีเรื่องมือเครื่องมือ
ช่างอีกอันหนึ่งอันร้านขายนะครับอะไรคะ
อันนี้เรียก
สว่างอะไรคะสว่านครับ
สว่านอ้านี่สว่านครับอันนี้ต้องมีต้องมี
ไฟฟ้ามั้ยสว่านอ้า
มีสว่านที่มีไฟฟ้าใช้ไฟฟ้า
ใช้ไฟฟ้าต้องไปเสียบปลั๊กค่ะหน้าแต่มี
สว่านที่ไม่ใช้ไฟฟ้าด้วยไม่ต้องเสียบ
ปลั๊ก
ใช้อะไรอามี
แบตเตอรี่อยู่ข้างในอ๋อมีแบตเตอรี่อยู่
ข้างใน
น่ะมีแบตเตอรี่อยู่ข้างในไม่ต้องเสียบ
ปลั๊ก
อ่าใช่เขาเป็นสว่าง
อตี้สวาทถ้าใช้กับอะไรคะ 5 สว่านใช้กับ
ไม้ครับมีใช้กับไม้ใช้กับอ่าใช้กับเหล็ก
ก็ได้อ้ะใช้กับปูนผนังปูนเนี่ยเหมือนผนัง
บ้านพี่เอกก็ได้แต่ครับแล้วเขาใช้สว่านทำ
อะไรที่มาให้ไปทำอะไรที่ปูนญี่ปุ่นอาใช้
สว่านเจาะจะออกไปนี่เขากำลังเจาะแค่นี้
เนาะจอดอกไม้ตาย 5 เจาะลงไปเป็นรูเป็นรู
มีเขากำลังเจาะไว้ในไม้เป็นรู
รูอ่าใช่ครับเป็นรู
อาหาน้าอานัคสว่านก็ใช้กับไม้ใช่ครับเจาะ
รูข้างครับอือ
ก็กูอะตี้มีอาบเครื่องมือช่างทั้งหมด 6
ห้าใช่ครับพี่ 6 ชนิดครับมีอะไรบ้างครับ
มีมีสว่านอยู่ตะวันนา
มี
ประแจไปครับอ่ะมีคีมเกม ami
ไขใครง่วงๆครับแล้วก็มี
ขอนร้อนหนาวโอเคแล้วก็มีอันสุดท้ายครับ
นี่เรื่อยลืมเลื่อยๆเย้ๆนะครับน้า
เลื่อย
เลื่อยใช้กับอะไรครับ 5 เรื่อยใช้กับอะไร
ได้กับไม้โอเคนี่ใช้เลื่อยนะครับอ่านัก
เรียนนักเรียนต้องจำจำคู๋ต้องจำคมีขวดดี
มีเกมให้เล่น
ต้องกำดำให้ทีมดำให้ดีนะครับอาเรื่อง
เรื่อยๆอ่ะใช้เลื่อยไม้ใช้เลื่อยไม้นะ
ครับอาขอนขอน่ะใช้กับปูค่ะกูโอเค
ไขควงใช้กับใช้กับสกรูโอเคนะครับอ่าคิม
ทีมใช้กับสายไฟใช้กับสายไฟจำทำให้ดีอาจจะ
ใช้ตัดใช่ครับอ่า
ประแจประแจใช้กับน๊อตน๊อตใช้ก้าใช้กับ
น๊อตเค
สว่านสว่านใช้กับไม้ 5 ติดต่อกับไม้กับกู
ไอ้เจาะโอเคพร้อมไหมครับ
เล่นเกม
ครับ
อ้ามือเหมือนเมื่อวานเหมือนเมื่อวาน
โอเคชอบเกมอ่าเดี๋ยวควรตี้เลือกก่อนเลือก
ก่อนว่าให้ให้ครูเอ๋ให้นักเรียนหาหา
อะไหล่นะครับห่าขั่วตี้เลือกเลือกเครื่อง
มือช่างเครื่องมือช่างอันนี้ครับอันนี้
เรื่อยเรื่อยๆใช้คู่กับอะไรครับ
ใช่คู๋รู้ใช้กับไม้ให้กับไม้โอเคต้องหา
อ่ะต้องหานี้นะหาอันนี้ว่าอยู่ที่ไหนอยู่
ที่ไหนโอเค
ที่นี่ได้ไหม Oh  My ใดๆๆอยู่นี่ต้องหา
ไหนนิอยู่หมายเลขหมายเลขอะไร
KR ตี้ครู f เปิดได้กี่ภาพค่ะค่ะครูเอ๋
เปิดได้กี่ภาพเขวอย่างเปิด 1 ภาพหรือยัง
เปิด
2555 ครับ
เอาก่อนนู้นเปิดสองภาพได้ 6 แล้วก็เมื่อ
วานเมื่อวาน
ภาพอาโอเคครั้งที่ 1 เปิด 2 ภาพอ่าเปิด
สองภาพใช่ไหมครับโอเคผู้เอกนะครับผมที่ 2
เปิด 1 ข้าวนะโอเคได้ครับโอเคโอเคอ่ะครู
เอ๋ / เลื่อยใช่ไหมเรื่อยๆเรื่อยใช้ทำ
อะไรนะอ่า
ไอ้เลื่อยไม้อ่ะเลื่อยไม้อยู่หมายขอเลข
หมายเลขอะไรครับ
ค่าหมายเลข 2 ค่ะ
เลือกหมายเลข 2 แล้วหน้าหมายเลข 2 ตรงนี้
อ้ะปวดที่จะเปิดแล้วนะเปิดแล้วนะโอเค
หนึ่ง
สอง
ถ้าดาวยังไม่เปิดกูอัดเปิด
โอเคสวัสดีจะเปิดแล้ว 1  2
ถ้าดาวโอ๊ย
[เพลง]
เอ๋ๆอีก 1 ครั้งหนึ่งครั้ง
หมายเลขหมายเลขหมายเลข 3 ค่ะอ้าคู่เอกคิด
ว่าอยู่หมายเลข 3 น่าใช่ๆหรือเม็ดใช่ครับ
ฮ่าๆๆใช่ไหมอ่ะขวดตีจะไม่เปิดแล้วนะครับ
อ่ะจะเปิดแล้วนะแม่เลยค่ะอ่า
สองอ่า
ถ้าด่า
ใช่
มาให้ได้
สูญโอเคกวนตี้ปิดอันนี้ก็ปิดจรอาติดก่อน
โอเค
เฟสจำดีเลือกก่อนเลือกก่อนว่าจะให้ครูเอ๋
หาหาอะไรนะครับถ้าต่อไปให้หา
หาอะไรหาอ่ะอันนี้อะไรครับขอนขอนใช้กับ
อะไรครับใช้กับกูอ่ะใช้กับตะปูมีผู้นัก
เรียนนักเรียนช่วยครูเอ๋หาหาตาปูหาตะปูนะ
ครับน้าว่าตะปูตะปูอยู่หมายเลขอะไรครับ
เดี๋ยวๆ
คล้ายๆนี้เปิดได้ 1 ภาพใช่ไหม 1 ค่าภาพ
แค่อยู่ไหนครับอยู่ทุ่ง
โอเคอยู่ไหนครับ
กลัวตีบอกให้บอกให้ไม่อยู่หมายเลข 2 อ่ะ
กูอัดรูเอรู้และเหล็กของอะไรหมายเลข
หมาย 3 ความจำได้ฮ่าๆปูจะปูไม่กูอยู่ไหน
อยู่ไหนอยู่
ไม่ใช่อยู่หมายเลข 1 ค่ะอ่าอ่ะครูเอ๋หรือ
การเลือกคู่เอกคลิปว่าอยู่หมายแรก
155 นักเรียนนักเรียนอ่านนักเรียนคิดว่า
ใช่หรือไม่ใช่ครับอ่าใช่หรือไม่ใช่หาตัว
ติดครับเปิดแล้วนะเปิดแล้วโอเคอ่าหน้า 1
ถ้าด่า
ใช่โอเคอ่า
อ่อนนี้เป็นตอนนี้อ่าได้ 1 คะแนน 1 คะแนน
[เพลง]
เนื้อหาอย่างกระจ่างได้ไหมนักเรียนยังตาม
ได้แม่นี้เรียกอะไรครับใครควงไขควงโอเค
แล้วให้ควงใช้ใช้กับอะไรครับใช้กับสกรู
ใช้กับสกรูโอเคนักเรียนช่วยช่วยครูพี่เอ๋
หาสักครูนะครับสักครู you  you หมายเลข
อะไรครับ
หนึ่งไม่ใช่ 5 ให้ 3 ไม่ใช่แล้วสี่ห้าหก
อ่าใช่ครับหรือเลือกได้ 1 ครั้งหนึ่ง
ครั้งหากเลือกแรกาหมายเลข 6 ใช่ไหมครับ
อ่านักเรียนคิดว่าคิดว่าอยู่หมายเลข 6
ไหมครับครูอยู่หรือไม่อยู่ครับหรือ 5456
อาเภอ
โอเคอะเวรเลือก 6 ครัวที่จะเกิดเปิดหมาย
เลข 6 แล้วนะหมายเลข 6 เลยค่ะอ่า
A1 หา 2 อ่า
ถ้า
ดาวๆไม่ใช่เธอไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่กว่าตีใส่คะแนน
ก่อนใส่คะแนนค่ะสู้ 0 โอเคอ่าอ่ะตอนนี้
ตอนนี้ตอนนี้ครูเอกจำได้นะว่าหนึ่งมีอะไร
2 มีอะไร 3 มีอะไรอะแล้ว 6 มีอะไรนะอ่า
ยังจำได้อยู่ไหมนักเรียนยังจำได้อยู่ไหม
ครับจ้าให้นั้นๆดีไหมไปซื้อตัวเลือกกัน
เลยเอาเดี๋ยวมีเครื่องมือช่างอะไรอีกครับ
นี่
หน้านี้อะไรครับ
คีมค่ะยิ่ง Mark  Kim ใช้กับอะไรครับใช้
กับสายไฟใช้กับสายไฟคีมใช้ตัดสายไฟอะนัก
เรียนนักเรียนต้องช่วยพี่เอ๋หาหา
ว่าหาว่าขี้คีมหน้าตัดสายไฟใช่ไหมอยู่
หมายเลขปลายครับปาดตัดสายไฟหมายเลขหมาย
เลขหมายเลขอะไรครับค่ะฮ่าๆๆๆมาให้เล็กๆ
อ๋อเพราะว่าเพราะว่าเราเปิดใหม่ได้ 6 ไป
แล้วใช่ไหมแล้วไม่ถูกได้สูตรแต่คราวนี้
คราวนี้กูอีกเลือกหมายเลข 6 นะแต่ถ้าใช่
หรือนี่ใครครับอ่า
โอเคอ่าคนที่จะเปิดแล้วนะครับอ่า
หนึ่งเต็ง
ซาดา
บ่ายเลข 6
ได้อีก 1 คะแนน
ได้อีก 1 คะแนนนี้กลัวตีใส่คะแนนแล้วนะ
เดี๋ยวกลัวตีจะไปใส่ไว้ตรงนี้และอีก 2
ข้อ 5 เหลืออีก 2 ข้อใช่ไหมต่อไปต่อไป
เดี๋ยวเราไปหาอะไรเครื่องมือช่างอีก 2
อันนะครับค่ะอ่าเดี๋ยวนะครัวตี้คิดว่ากู
เอ๋น่าจะรู้แล้วล่ะว่าสองอันนี้อยู่ที่
ไหนให้เอาอันนี้ก่อนอันนี้เรียกอะไรครับ
ประแจประแจประแจใช้กับอะไรครับอ่ะถ้าใช้
กับน๊อตน้าใสกับเนาะตมีน็อตตัวผู้น็อตตัว
เมียเคหานักเรียนช่วยพี่เอ๋หาหาน็อตนะวัน
นอน not  you หมายเลขอะไรไอ้น็อตอยู่หมาย
เลขอะไรครับ
หมายเลข 3 ค่ะฮ่าๆๆอยู่ไปเล็กอ่าว
หน้าโอเคขวดตี้เปิดหมายเลข 2 ให้ไม่ใช่
ไม่ใช่
คลิกเลยนิดเลยนะแพ้หมายเลข 3 ใช่มั้ยโอเค
หมายเลข 3 คนที่จะเปิดหมายเลข 3 นะครับ
ว่ามีมีน็อตจะมีน็อตหรือเปล่ามีหรือไม่มี
ครับอ่าจะเปิดแล้วนะค่ะหึเนื้อเพลง
สอง
ถ้า
ได้
แย่มีน็อต
3 คะแนนไปเหตุได้ 3 คะแนนโอเคอ่า
หมดหรือยังหรือยังอ๋ออ๋อมีอันสุดท้ายอัน
สุดท้ายเป็นอะไรครับ
เดี๋ยวนะเรียกว่าอะไรนะอันนี้ไหมไม่เอา
ไม่ใช่หรออันนี้เรียกอะไรใช่ไม่ใช่ไขควง
ไขควงอันสุดท้ายอันนี้ไม่ครับใช่ม้อนท์
ไม่ซ้อนใช่ขอกลัวดิกลัวเตี้ยใช้เวลานานๆ
ให้กูเอ๋ลืม
[เพลง]
ตี
สุดท้ายๆอันนี้ไม่เหงารแจถ้าไม่ใช่
อาจารย์แกนี่มันสุดท้ายอันนี้ครับ
นี่อันสุดท้ายคุณเรียกอะไรครับตาลหน้า
โอเคก็วานสว่านอ่าสว่านใช้ใช้ทำอะไรครับ
ใช้เจาะค่ะอ่าอ่ะใช้จ่อมีอ่านะเดี๋ยวนัก
เรียนไม้หายให้กับไม้ได้ใช้กับปูนผนังปูน
ได้ใช่ครับอ่ะแล้วก็โอเคเดี๋ยวนักเรียน
ช่วยช่วยพี่เอ๋หาหา
สว่านเจาะนะครับอ่าว่าอยู่อยู่อยู่หมาย
เลขอะไรอ่ะอยู่หมายเลข 1 หมายเลข 2 หมาย
เลข 3 ที่
หมายเลข 5 หรือหมายเลข 6 นั้นได้ R
crew เองคิดดู
เม็กซ์ไม่ซ่าไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่อยู่ไหนครับหมาย
เลข 2 ค่ะอ๋ออ๋อเหรอเอกคิดว่าหมายเลข 2
ใช่ไหมให้กลัวตี้จะเปิดเปิดหมายเลขอื่น
ไม่เปิดสิบหายเลข 2 โอเค
สวัสดีเปิดใหม่แรกเปิดหมายเลขอะไรคะหมาย
เลข 6 มีนะหมายเลขของไม่มีเป็นสายไฟหรอ
มันสายไฟแล้วหมายเลข 5 มีไม่เอา
ไม่ได้เปิด i5 ไม่ได้เปิดงั้นป่วยพี่ไม่
เปิดไม่ได้คืนไมค์เปิด
หมายเลข 4 เปิดไหมยังไม่ได้เปิดไม่ได้พ่อ
ยังไม่ได้เปิดสองหมายเลขงั้นกวนตีไปเปิด
หมายเลข 3 ก่อนหมายเลข 3 มีมะ not  not
มีกล้วยจำได้ละโอเค Ra แล้วหมายเลข 2 ขวด
ดิไม่เปิดกูเห็นเลือกหมายเลขนี้กวนติเปิด
หมายเลข 100 บาทตะปูตะปูอ่ะฮ่าๆๆเก๋ๆ
เปิดหมายเลขหน้านี้
เดาไอ้สองตัวนี้อะไรใช่ไหม
เพราะว่า 4 กับ 5 ยังไม่ได้เปิดเลยเปิด
จริงนะไอ้สองตัว
สังหารจอดอ๋ออ๋อแล้วหมายเลข 4 นี่เอ่อน่า
จะเป็นอะไรอ่ะกลัวตีเปิดเลยครู
สกรู or  School ยังไม่ปูไหมนะมีสกรูแล้ว
ก็มีสองแล้วก็มีอะไรอีกที่เรายังหาไม่เจอ
มีสกุลโง่มีสกรูเสน่ห์
เลื่อยหรอ
เลื่อยใช่ไหมสักรู้กับเรื่อยๆ
ขอแก้หาสักครู่กับเรื่อยต้องอยู่หมายเลข 2
หรือหมายเลข 4 หรือหมายเลข 5 นี่แหละอ้า
เดี๋ยวปวดที่แม่เหล็กแม่เหล็ก 2 เปิดหมาย
เลข
สว่านมันใจเว็บถูกแน่สว่านเหรอ
โอเคกว่าตี้เปิดหมายเลข 5 ก่อนเปิดหมาย
เลข 5 น้อ
[เพลง]
เอาคะแนน
ว้าวหานะตอนนี้จะหมดเวลาเดี๋ยวเราทบทวน
ครับครู A4 คะแนนนักเรียนกี่คะแนนนัก
เรียนแบงค์ขี่กันแนนครับฮ่าๆ
ไม่ทราบนักเรียนคอมเม้นนะคะนักเรียนได้
เปลี่ยนหน้าเลือกได้กี่คะแนนครับ
ถ้ากูอัดที่เราจะทบทวนนะคะ 5 ครับผมอ่า
เดี๋ยวนะกลับไปทบทวนตั้งแต่อันแรกเลยครับ
นี่มีอะไรคะไรคะ
เรื่อยเรื่อยๆเรื่อยๆเรื่อยใช้ทำอะไรครับ
ใช้เลื่อยไม้เลื่อยไม้ใช่ครับอาเครื่อง
มือต่อไปไหมครับ
ค้อนค่ะขอหน้าค้อนใช้กับกระปุๆของจะกลับ
ก็กูข้อศอกตะปูป๊อกๆเคต่อไปครับ R  R ไข่
ควรขายควงงอ่ะใครควงใช้ไขขายอะไรครับขาย
สกรู
อ่ะใช่ครับไขควงใช้ไขสกรูตอบๆ
อ่ะอ่ะครีมทางหน้าครีมครีมใช้ตัดท้ายตัด
ตัดสายไฟอ่าใช่ครับ
ตอบๆประแจค่ะประแจโอเคประแจใช้ใช้ขันขัน
น๊อตอ่ะได้ครับขันน็อตหน้า not มีน๊อตตัว
ผู้แล้วก็น็อตตัวเมียนะครับโอเคป่ะป้าย
สุดท้ายอันสุดท้ายครับ
อะไรคะ 5 สว่านสว่านครบท้ายออกอะไรน่าใช้
เจาะรูเจาะรูเจาะรูที่ไม้ก็ได้ก็รู้ที่
ปูนผนังปูนได้ใช่ครับมากก็ว้าวโอเค
[เพลง]
อ้าวนี้ได้ 4 คะแนนคู๋ดีใจวิจัย
ดีใจสวัสดีปีใหม่จ้ายาวันนี้ก็เป็นคลิป
สุดท้ายของปี
2021 หน่อยครับใครแล้วเดี๋ยวเรากลับมา
เจอกันใหม่ในปีไหนครับปีหน้า
ปีหน้าปีปีหน้าปี
2010  22 เรากลับมาเจอกันอากัปมาเจอกัน
นะครับโอเคสำหรับวันนี้ควรตี้กับครูพี่
เอ๋ต้องลาไปก่อนครับน้าครับสวัสดีครับพี่
เอ๋สวัสดีครับสวัสดีครับนักเรียนครับผม
ถ้านักเรียนบ๊ายบายอ่ะกลัวติดต้องพูดว่า
ต้องพูดว่าสวัสดี
รับปีใหม่ด้วยครับมามากดีปีใหม่ค่ะไม่
ครับผมบ๊ายบายน
[เพลง]